[Music]
the body of shireen abu aklar is carried
through the town of janine in the
occupied west bank the veteran al
jazeera reporter was shot dead while
covering a raid by israeli forces
another journalist was also shot and
injured the palestinian health ministry
says they were hit by bullets fired by
israeli soldiers
we made ourselves clear to the army on
the passers-by indicating that we are
the press then within seconds there was
the first shot i told them that we are
being targeted we are being shot at i
turned and found shireen on the ground
the israeli military says its forces
came under attack in janine and that
they fired back
there was no exchange of fire so there
is no possibility whatsoever that a
palestinian have shot sharing
the israeli army always uses these
excuses to cover up the crimes they are
committing against palestinians
including palestinian journalists
israeli raids in the occupied west bank
have intensified in recent weeks after a
series of attacks inside israel the
janine refugee camp has become a
stronghold for resistance against the
israeli occupation
abu agla had worked for al jazeera for
20 years colleagues described her as
brave kind and a voice of palestinians
i'm sure there will be lots of calls
from around the world we get a lot of
support from
human rights organizations governments
who will be looking at at what happened
here and on why a journalist
has been shot dead
uh journalists you know killing
journalists shooting the messenger is
equivalent to a war crime so we need to
know what has happened the world needs
to know what has happened
qatar's foreign ministry put out a tweet
saying the israeli occupation killed al
jazeera journalist shireen abu aklar by
shooting her in the face while wearing
the press vest and a helmet she was
covering their attack in jeanine refugee
camp this state-sponsored israeli
terrorism must stop and unconditional
support to israel must end
israel says it's launched an
investigation into what happened it says
it does not target journalists but some
human rights activists say they have
little faith in the israeli justice
system
there are
human rights organizations for example
like bet salem and israeli human rights
organization
that decided a long time ago that they
are no longer going to
even interact with the complaint system
within the israeli army
because it is not serious
it doesn't find israeli soldiers guilty
al-jazeera is calling for a transparent
investigation into the death of shireen
abu akla few palestinians think that's
likely to happen victoria gatenbee al
jazeera